vois que ça marche luery est-ce qu'il va
elle est une pro nous n'avons pas de mouvement
pas un bruit d'ombre je vais
là-bas c'est ça j'ai rencontré un mur
quelque chose va bien
[Musique] à
quel point c'est mauvais quand une balle est passée
j'ai un homme à terre nous avons un tireur d'élite
des armes de gros calibre demandant à
nouveau des instructions vous avez un accent pas
américain
vous êtes bâclé nous vous utilisions les gars sur
lui
où  s'il venait si j'étais toi
je commencerais à parler Isaac que veux-tu
je veux apprendre à te connaître je reçois un
coup non non non non seconde tu touches ce
droit pour ta mort c'est vrai
mais c'est sur sa famille  ne le reconnaîtra
pas
c'est une maison d'hydratation la même
mort de masse vous saignerez faire face c'est une
extension de mon œil vous vous fanez vous vous
fanez à quel point la gâchette fantastique est une
extension de mon meilleur pour parler sport
au fusil est un  extension de moi ce que
tu supportes avec son jeûne et je te frappe
[Musique]
toi